all right you're done hopefully you
started with the provided build URI
matcher function we begin with a new URI
matcher that contains the no match
function because we don't want the root
node to match anything this is typical
behavior to make the code more easy to
read I'm making a shortcut to the
weather contract content Authority our
to base you are eyes are pretty simple
since we've already defined path weather
and path location in the contract we can
just assign them to their corresponding
integer constants there for path weather
we're going to match a path with just
one additional item weather with
location we're going to match a path
that just has one additional item on it
because location can be a string we have
to match it with an asterisk for weather
with location and date we're going to
match to path items the first one of
course will be our location a string but
the second one will be our date which
will always be a number because of that
we can match it with the hash sign